we are now live on youtube i'll just
share the link in the chat box you can
refer the link
uh
to see the recording after the session
thank you
and by the time we begin with the
session it would be really great if you
all could tell me what is your
educational background
and also what are your research
interests it would be great to know more
about you all and also um
help us understand
what exactly you are looking for so that
we could help you with the best
hi honda uh so bse in biochemistry from
which
university
and what are your research and trust as
well it would be great to know in the
chat box thank you
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all
uh for the free webinar on machine
learning for biomedical data course
so data science is a desired profession
that brings together diverse skills that
are needed to handle data and turn it
into useful information some of the
highest paying and interesting jobs are
for data scientists at high-tech
companies like apple google and uber and
also the healthcare companies as well
areas of science where a tremendous
amount of complex digital data is being
generated are biotechnology and
healthcare and these industries are
actually relying on scientific
discoveries about biology and
translating the basic understanding of
biological processes into useful
insights for drug discovery
improved treatment efficacy as well as
early detection of risks and even
anticipation of disease progression
so in this course we will cover
practical and conceptual aspects of
machine learning in application to high
throughput biomedical data
using various tools and r and python
throughout the course so the students
will get an understanding of
opportunities and limitations as well of
machine learning in the context of
pre-clinical and clinical research
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our bioinformatics community which is
managed by pine biotech
so before we start with today's talk i
would like to introduce us we are a u.s
based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world due to this fast growth our
team is working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
i am honored to have been working with a
team that collectively has an amazing
experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr alfred tauber who comes from
a medical background with an expertise
in oncology immunology and biochemistry
of inflammation
and one of his major projects is the
establishment of the troubled
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr laurent brodsky is the director of
tribal bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career he has developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis these have been
widely used in basic and translational
research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical rnd agriculture and basic
research
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right julia panna who is an expert
bioinformatician and helped prepare many
of the materials that we would use in
the course avi tidovsky who is a
computer scientist and leads the
development of the t bioinfo platform
that we would be using dr harpreet has
an expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
on biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases as
well
dr harpreet looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development as well for
the omics logic dr mohit mazumdar who is
an expert bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
has been looking after
the companies developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and a
project lead for omixlogic training and
research fellowship
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing online community
of bioinformaticians in training ranging
from high school students to faculty and
researchers in top universities around
the world our team offers big data
analysis tools and quality learning
resources like courses projects and
tutorials in programs designed around
various topics we discuss bioinformatics
approaches for processing analysis
integration and interpretation of
multi-omics data from oncology
neuroscience agrobiology and infectious
diseases
i encourage you all to sign up now with
me for free on our portal
omixlogiclearn.com
so
let me just post the link to the portal
here
it is one of the best ways we can
explore the world around us at the
molecular level with zero equipment or
lab cost
so please make sure you are on
learn.ormixlogic.com
i request you all to please also ensure
that
you are signed up on the portal as we
are going to get some hands-on practice
today and also explore the various
courses related to data science in the
next part of the session
please type in a one or uh yes once you
are signed up on the portal and all set
for the hands-on practice in the later
part of the session
thank you kenny timmy
i would be giving in a minute for
everyone to take their time
to go to the portal and sign up real
quick
once you are signed up please make sure
that you have an updated profile now
when when i say updated profile i mean
that you all should have an updated
profile picture
please have your social accounts
connected to the profile itself facebook
linkedin instagram and uh twitter could
be one and
google scholar as well if you're there
and then please add a brief bio about
yourself
we would be monitoring your achievements
here from your profile and you would be
able to uh also look at the courses and
the projects other programs that you are
working on right now and get their
certificates and download the same from
your profile itself
so it's important for you to please have
an updated profile
and
make sure that you have your name in the
correct title case and not in caps or in
small letters because that's what is
going to come on your certificate
okay so before i pass it on to
ilya a ceo pine biotech to talk further
about the session i would really like to
have a poll just to understand more
about you all
the poll would be on for
a minute
uh india i would like to pass it on to
you there's some technical technical
glitch in uh
having the poll on you can start and
after you maybe i'll just have the book
thank you
okay could you please make me a co-host
like you said yes yeah i've made you the
co-host
all right thank you welcome everyone to
this webinar i'm happy to see you all
and welcome to omnibus logic so what
we'll do today is we'll kind of briefly
talk about this upcoming program
and explain how you can use various
resources that we've prepared for you to
learn about biomedical data analysis
machine learning as well as some coding
in r and python
so first of all why machine learning why
data science so as you probably know
some of the highest paying jobs and
interesting tasks are being prepared to
tackle uh data in a variety of ways and
especially this is happening in the
world of biomedical discovery
pharmaceutical biotechnology companies
and the major objective for these
companies is to take biological insights
and translate them into applications
and a lot of times to look deeper just
like we look in the microscope to
understand the details of a biological
sample today we turn to computational
analysis because the data is becoming
more and more complex large variable and
essentially
knowing how to use some of these tools
can be a major component of your job
description or it could be something
that just drives your career and it
allows you to explore data sets and gain
meaningful biological as well as
clinical insights so we'll talk a little
bit more about the types of applications
in a little bit
so what we want to do in this program is
really focus on some of the applications
of data science as well as machine
learning
to different types of data these data
sets could describe challenges in
diagnostics when we talk about clinical
applications they could be discovery of
targets that could be applicable to
biotechnology or pharmaceutical
companies it could also be for basic
research where we look at environmental
samples clinical samples
animal models of human disease and try
to understand what is the data telling
us about a particular condition
phenotype or biological process now i
think the most exciting thing is that
there are
huge amounts of data available for
anyone to learn from and analyze on
repositories like the national center
for biotechnology information or ncbi
where you have layers of information
from processed information that has
already been analyzed and interpreted
and put into review articles or
publications but including all the way
down to the raw data and especially for
the raw data
recently there has been an analysis in
2021
where over 15 petabytes of sra data
which is raw data raw sequencing reads
that have been deposited on ncbi so what
is 15 petabytes 15 petabytes is 15 000
terabytes of raw data raw sequence
archives
now that includes some process data as
well there's over a hundred thousand
public data sets for geo which is gene
expression omnibus transcriptomic data
and there are a lot of over six million
genbank sequences which means over six
million uh individual um
uh
species that have been sequenced and
their genomes have been assembled now a
lot of this is driven by what's
happening right now what are the hot
topics in research including clinical
research including basic research and
one of the major drivers i think right
now
is the pandemic which has brought about
almost real-time sequencing uh to the
forefront really allowing many of us to
not only learn about the impacts of the
pandemic but also look at how we can
contribute to the understanding of this
pandemic
now when it comes to such a diverse
series of data we need to understand
what are the properties and challenges
associated with each one onyx data is a
variety of comprehensive views of a
particular type of data now a lot of
times this is generated using what's
called high throughput technologies
these technologies include phenomics
genomics epigenomics and transcriptomics
and all of these
are relying on high throughput or
automated technologies to generate huge
collections of data sets now because
they are so variable and they speak
about different molecular properties
you have to rely on computational
technologies to be able to
learn from these data sets analyze these
data sets explore these data sets and
make use of these data sets and these
computational technologies are basically
rooted in data science and so in this
program that we're going to
introduce you today to we're going to
focus on some of these data science
skills that you need to have to be able
to efficiently process analyze and
visualize such complex biomedical data
so what are some of the things that
we're going to cover in this program
first of all we're going to talk about
analytical methods
how to visualize and analyze the data
complexity and reduce it so that we can
extract meaningful insights
we'll introduce you to the terminology
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence and biomedical discovery so
that when you read the paper and you
hear about a method
you know what it does and you know what
it means we'll also provide you with
some project examples so you'll see how
other people have used machine learning
now machine learning is used in many
different ways and so you'll see how
it's not just
clustering or classification you'll see
how different types of machine learning
methods are actually used in a variety
of tasks related to the whole process
from getting raw data to then making it
useful for analysis or structuring it
cleaning it preparing it for
analysis and then finally turning it
into a model or learning from it
essentially
using the complex patterns in that data
now as a result what we expect the
participant to gain out of this program
is to really have an understanding
of how machine learning algorithms are
used in analysis of vomit's data you'll
understand the differences between
different types of machine learning
models and different types of problems
that they can be applied to you'll also
see practical examples so you'll have a
sense of how other experts have used
this and what are the specific
challenges that they had to address to
make their project work and we will
introduce you to some of the popular and
user-friendly python and our packages so
that you gain
practical skills you can actually use
these skills to code yourself and you
will be able to read other people's code
understanding what packages are being
used and how to use them yourselves and
so these are going to include some
examples that we'll actually do today in
this session so that you get a sense of
how can you get all of this done in a
short period of time
so the data science program the omics
logic data science program is really
structured around these four different
things understanding the various omix
data types learning to explore them then
to try big data analysis in the context
of a project and then to understand the
link between data and biology how do you
actually master biological
interpretation leveraging some of these
tools so let's talk a little bit about
the syllabus so the syllabus of this
program is organized into three
different parts introduction
methods
an in-depth review of methods
and finally the project section so all
together we'll have three different
sections the first one is then we'll
introduce you to the relevant
terminology and key concepts to refresh
your memory and get you started so that
you're well oriented in this whole field
of omics and machine learning
the second one we'll talk about methods
that will give you a practical sense of
commonly used methods and functions for
analysis of our mixed data starting from
exploration to statistical testing to
supervising and supervised machine
learning as well as deep learning and
then finally some project examples so
that you have a sense of applications
for such methods and
after you complete the full program we
hope that you will have the confidence
to understand and analyze data that you
can conduct independently to a data set
of your choice and we'll also introduce
you by the way to some examples at the
end so you
can kind of try it out before you do
your own independent work
so the program itself is going to
combine interactive sessions just like
we're having today
in each session you will find additional
links to asynchronous resources that
review and enrich the covered topics so
it's the live sessions plus the
self-guided study materials that you can
practice and go deeper into if you want
to learn more about the technical the
theoretical or the application of the
particular topic
and as we kind of talk about a lot of
topics in general i want to kind of give
you a high level overview of each one of
these topics
so a lot of what we are talking about
when we say words like transcriptomics
genomics or metagenomics might be
confusing to some of you and so we will
start in the beginning to kind of
explain what is the link between
omics data
the biological
features the molecular features that
they describe and how can the data that
comes from a an automated process like
sequencing can be used to essentially
prepare it for analysis so we want to
link together the biological
the technical and the data components
together to kind of make sense of the
important terminology and give you a
practical sense of what does this data
look like and how does it work in terms
of using it for data analysis
then in the second part
in the second part we'll talk about the
machine learning topics unsupervised and
supervised learning how are these
methods used for various tasks such as
visualization organization of data
finding signal in noisy omix data as
well as things like predictive analysis
and feature selection so to use these
methods you will need to understand how
they work what are the inputs what are
the variables what are the different
settings and available packages that
combine multiple functions that make the
methods that we described easy to deploy
right so you can understand the method
in detail but then as you want to deploy
it you want some user-friendly or some
kind of a short cut to essentially
launch and train that model so that's
what you will learn in this second part
you will learn to load data select a
method and run it to get an output that
you can interpret for that particular
model
using these principles we will then
review additional methods that are
useful for biomedical discovery that
include network analysis such as pathway
analysis for biologists generalized
linear models that are used to
distinguish between expression profiles
of transcripts for example and complex
transfer atomic data as well as deep
learning models that can be used for
specific types of situations to improve
accuracy and decrease feature
engineering which is a lot of what
conventional machine learning relies on
and then we'll also talk about the need
to combine various machine learning
models into a series of steps to achieve
more complex tasks for example when we
talk about single cell data
and finally we will talk about specific
use cases that can show you how the
methods we reviewed have been used by
researchers to find meaningful insights
in complex experiments biological
samples animal models or patient data
and so with the few examples we review
as case studies you can also then
develop a project of your own
to fi or follow our asynchronous
tutorials to reproduce an analysis that
you can improve upon turning it into a
novel study so what are some of these
projects
we'll talk about cancer macrophages
which is an important part of the immune
system and the immune response to tumor
growth we'll talk about different types
of pandemics like enterovirus malaria or
ebola virus we'll talk about modeling
cancer precision medicine where we can
find biomarkers and learn how different
patients respond to different treatments
we'll talk about tumor micro environment
but we'll also introduce projects that
are not clinical in essence things like
drought resistance or different stresses
that are important for crop production
and environmental preservation
so as a result i think that you will
really get a full overview of the data
science kind of a
process in biomedical research
to understand how different stages of
analysis work together to help define
the hypothesis as well as prepare the
data for meaningful application of
machine learning for big data practical
challenges so as a result you'll be able
to take a data set make it useful and
then explore it from a biological
perspective to understand really what
does it mean
as a result of completing all of these
different steps you will also get a
certificate so as
already mentioned by somalica you will
get the certificate after completing all
of these different steps on the omixler
portal
so now to kind of explain how all of
these different resources are linked
together and how to use them i want to
give you a practical sense of how this
works so for those of you that have not
signed up yet please go on to learn
onyxlogic.com
and sign up and create an account and
then i will show you a couple of just
really simple practical examples to
illustrate what we will do so this is
the page where you have registered on
the learn portal for this webinar and as
you can see it explains everything that
i've described today
and right here on the top if you already
have an account we can go to the courses
page
and what i will do is i will take one
example from the asynchronous materials
that we will go through to just kind of
illustrate what will be going on so if
you go into the search tab right here on
the course page if you go into the
search go to data science
and you will see here
bioml in python and bioml in r
as well as some additional resources
that you can look at but right now we'll
just take one example from this
introduction to data science in r
and let's take a look at some of the
basic tasks that you have
to get started with as you are
considering this program
so this is uh the course i'm just going
to paste the link again in chat
for those of you that want to follow
along
and in this course this is again our
coding course two introduction to data
science or bioml you will see all of the
different
courses that we have there's about 10
courses here that go from very very
basic things or how to load data and
check for variable data all the way to
advanced supervised machine learning
right so let's take a look i'm going to
use
this
course right here or this lesson right
here anyone without a paid subscription
can access this lesson it's called data
processing and visualization
and basically what it talks about is
once you have a table once you have a
table of gene expression a table of otu
taxonomy in metagenomic sequencing of
the microbiome or whether you have some
kind of frequency of mutations across
the genome of a virus you will have a
table in this table you will have
different types of data this data can
include continuous numeric data such as
transcriptomic gene expression it could
have names of samples and names of genes
or otus and it can also have categories
so these could be groups of samples that
maybe define a particular type of
samples that you have
now to analyze such data you can explore
different methods of visualization that
summarize the data in a meaningful way
and that can include
crosstabs or pivot tables they can
include box plots that summarize
statistical properties of each sample or
each group
and they can include continuous data
like scatter plots that allow us to find
relationships and organization of data
that could be potentially
interesting from a signal standpoint so
as we go through this introduction
you'll kind of learn about some of these
methods and then we can jump into the
breakdown of this code now what's
important
is first of all loading the data and so
here you have an example of how you load
a data set
that is already on github
uh well this particular example is on
our portal but we'll also be introducing
you to how to use github to kind of
manage and organize your code as well as
data sets then you can pre-process and
transform your data for analysis so here
you can see that we can for example
prepare the data matrix from the data
frame that we have to create some
numeric data for analysis
then you can also
load a library a library is just a
compilation of different functions that
are going to be useful for the analysis
and streamline your analysis and in that
data you now have an option to create a
visualization like a box plot right so
after we learn
about how this code is organized and
what are the different elements of this
code we can actually go in to practice
it yourself right here in the browser so
let's go into practice it yourself
and let's try over here
to run this analysis so you see that now
you have a console
you click on run
and after this step is complete you have
a message success running code and
essentially you get an output that was
predefined for you to make sure that
you're following the steps now here
nothing really has to change it's
already made for you what you can do
though is you can check what's in this
data so let's go in here and we'll edit
it and we will put in head
df which is the name of our data frame
to understand what is in our data so
after we have calculated the mean which
is right here we now see what is in our
data now this is a little bit difficult
to understand as you can see there's a
lot of different columns there's a lot
of different numbers it's not very clear
what do they actually mean
a more useful way to look at this data
is to actually visualize it what's in it
and so here we have a
plot boxplot histogram and heatmap but
all of it is connected into one single
piece of code and as a result we might
be a little bit confused as to what
exactly are we looking at so let's
modify this a little bit here we also
have descriptive statistics converted
into matrix drawing a box plot a heat
map and a histogram so let's start with
the box part so we'll just remove this
run it
and now we have a box block now what is
a box plot a box plot essentially shows
us
how the data for each sample that we
have on the x-axis can be summarized
using the interquartile range
maximum and minimum values outliers as
well as the median line for each one
this gives us a sense of what's in the
data that is fairly complex we have here
a bunch of samples and inside each
sample we have certain level of
variability that we should be using to
understand differences between what we
see right here which is the names of
groups or conditions that we're trying
to interpret now what's important about
this visualization is that it should
immediately give us a sense of how ready
is this data for downstream analysis
right so if we want to analyze a
difference between normal like samples
and let's say basal or luminal breast
cancer subtypes we want to understand
that within each group there's some
consistency that we can rely on to make
sure that these samples accurately
represent the condition that we're
studying
and that is really what this whole
course is about this course is going to
go into the detail of the code but also
link it with the biological question
that you're trying to ask to really
understand
what is the process of going from raw
data to an answer to a question that is
either biological in nature clinical in
nature or has some intro interpretable
insights for somebody working in
industry like biotechnology or
pharmaceutical
so with this i want to really make sure
that it's clear
that in the context of the program we
will cover a lot of topics in sessions
like we did today going through code and
running examples
at the end you will be able to download
all of this code you can copy it and we
will use what's called google colab to
make sure that all of the code that you
work on is not only tested automatically
in on our platform but also is reviewed
by someone so that at the end you come
out with a whole series of
full code from beginning loading
exploration finally to training a
machine learning model and then
interpreting your results and all of
that by the way is going to be
integrated on your own profile so at the
end
when you share your outcome you will see
all of the different projects and all
the different courses that you have
completed you will also have the option
to develop an independent project so
here after you have a certain number of
points after you've completed the
minimum requirements you will be able to
apply this to a data set of your own
essentially turning it into a mini
publication that starts from
submitting this project right here on
this learn portal that will guide you
through all the different steps that you
need to take and then you can actually
use this to maybe go for a poster
presentation or a full publication if
you have a meaningful project
so with that i want to make sure that i
answer any questions that you might have
before i pass it on to dr mohit zumba
who will talk about some of the methods
that we will discover in this program
are there any questions
okay so if there are no questions i will
pass it on to dr mohit mazumdar he's a
computational biologist and a project
mentor here with omixlogic and he will
talk to you a little bit more about the
curriculum how to sign up and where you
can find all developers
over to your document
yeah am i audible
yes you're honorable
thank you
hello everyone
my name is mohit majumdar and i am a
bioinformatician by education and since
last 12 years i have been practicing and
applying bioinformatics for research and
now both for student driven research
projects and academic and industrial
collaboration so during my phd i learned
to apply machine learning algorithms to
variety of sequence based data sets and
we're able to design and complete
several research projects that are now
published in peer-reviewed journals
so with this
incredible growth
i think
big data has turned out to be a
remarkable career choice for many today
industries from various domain offered
different positions for big data
professionals that includes biology and
healthcare too so some of the topics
that we are covering in this
in this program are quite relevant to
the industry
so
from a data perspective i think we have
already heard from elia a lot about it
so what i think is what makes biology
unique from other realm
is its sheer size
so i i think that for example like for
example if i have to give you an example
a typical genome of a microbe which
might have 4000 genes
and if we assume that there are like
1000 meaningful distinct variants for
each gene then that's like almost 1
billion samples to test so i mean if you
if you consider that sort of uh
volume of data it's just really really
very big
so uh genomic researchers they utilize
biometrics to speed up this related to
analyzing dna sequences ultimately
helping inform teens looking to come
back to given disease so kubit vaccines
and cancer research are two areas of
genomics that is greatly helped by
bioinformatician and bioinformatics
similarly in the case of drugs
as vaccines and future cancer treatment
current pharmaceuticals can also become
more efficient and they are moving in
the rates in that direction with almost
instant analyzation capability
afforded by bioinformatics right
and machine learning machine learning
helps to make databases more searchable
and trackable by biologists whose human
understanding and instinct are paired
with power of ai and that power of ai
can create a kind of an investigative
ecosystem so that's something that we
all are looking forward to
about this program i think
our team
and industry within our team and with
our industry and academic collaborators
contributing and developing this unique
program that takes you through the
omixlogic learning experience and
provide hands-on training through the
powerful ebay info platform
so uh let me tell you about the intended
outcomes and some of the learning
objectives of the program so some of the
things that we will be doing is that we
will be learning about the terminologies
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence in biomedical
discovery
we will be understanding the analytical
methods for processing visualizing and
analysis of complex biomedical data
we will be understanding the machine
learning taxonomy and also the commonly
used machine learning algorithms which
are used to analyze different kind of
biomedical data
we will have hands-on practice
in application of standard unsupervised
and supervised machine learning methods
to various types of data such as
genomics transcriptomic metagenomics
imaging data and clinical data
you will be becoming familiar with
project examples where machine learning
was used effect effectively to achieve
meaningful results
and then you will be able to understand
differences between machine learning
categories uh
i mean categories of algorithms in
different machine learning uh algorithms
in different categories uh which would
be like what kind of data sets they are
good for
and what kind of problems they are good
for and they are applied to
and then we will understand about
different applications of machine
learning uh in the aspects of project
design
uh objectives and then we will learn
about python packages for data
visualization and analysis of uh and
using analysis using machine learning
methods by python and then apply machine
learning techniques to analyze public
domain data all in your own data sets so
those are some of the things that are
intended to uh come out of this program
so
this course
uh and this program is designed as a
combination of online resources then
there will be practical assignments and
uh there will be live sessions live
workshops that will be conducted uh
through zoom
and throughout this program we will
review several project examples that
demonstrates
the success
or the limitations of conventional
machine learning methods and also deep
learning methods using data from public
repositories
okay so now let's uh go to the sessions
that what sessions will be the next so i
wanted to give you an overview of what
is coming next so in the next session
uh that will be the second session uh we
in this session we will learn about
various omics data that are generated
through high throughput technology and
contains detailed information for
example genomics transcriptomic uh
metagenomics
and then we learn about the overview of
approaches and we will learn from used
use cases for various types of machine
learning algorithms for clustering and
classification to visualize and
interpret multi-dimensional data
the first session in this session we
will overcome some of the challenges to
compress complex information into an
interpretable
representation
representation accurately
and in the fifth session in this session
we will learn about the very critical
challenge to organize data using complex
patterns in a space
that is beyond human imagination and we
will be in the multi-dimensional space
as i said
and in the sixth session we will be
learning about the application of
supervised machine learning for
classification in this session we will
be learning about uh how do we train or
training an algorithm
to find and use patterns that we think
are meaningful
uh in the seventh session in this
session we will learn about feature
selection and gene signature
construction
and after that in the next session we
will be using regression and
generalized linear models to understand
relationships in data by finding
associations between a pattern and
influence
and then
in the next session which would be the
ninth session and this would be in
november uh we will be learning about
this of interaction between many players
for example
across tissues uh across time points or
across individuals
so uh after that uh in the 10th session
we will be combining uh machine learning
methods and and we'll be understanding
that how machine learning methods and
with predictive modeling we are going
towards uh
automation so we will be learning up
from some project examples uh to
understand how machine learning is
helping in automation
and then in the next session we will be
diving deep into the
deep learning to make a network a
deep learning approach which is we will
learn for classification so there are
different types of deep learning methods
that we will be learning about and
implementation of time series data
and then it would be about the project
so after learning and applying all these
different tools
that are available for
for a data scientist to be applied on
different types of biological data we
will be want we would be working on uh
with participants to develop a
project or to be able to work on group
projects or ongoing projects so here we
will be discussing about project design
uh understanding of the used cases for
data analysis
and the need for uh you know data
structuring uh for before you go to the
analysis and while doing this we will be
also taking you through some of the
examples and those examples are from
clinic
so in the clinic
in the clinical condition i'm sorry
let me go back to the previous slide
yes for the clinical condition i think
we would be talking about
biomarkers diagnostics treatments and
also drug repurposing
and after that we would be talking about
the industry
challenges so we'll be talking about
parma and biotech companies and their
need for machine learning and data
mining
data mining projects
so overall we will be taking you through
some of the resources and some of the
problems from the 20th century and learn
about the importance of these
technologies in the future
and we will be using
[Music]
tools such as r and also python to
extract meaningful insights from large
biological data sets learn practice and
achieve biological greatness with
concise exercises and interesting
challenges right in front of in comfort
of your own browser so that is one of
the advantages of this program and to
tell you more about the resources and
and
the data sets and the opportunities i
would like to
invite our community manager
uh mr nalika and i will be happy to take
any questions that you might have
for me
uh so we have a very consistent question
coming up that what about the beginners
uh how will they start with the
languages or let's say data science or
machine learning because there are a lot
many topics which are covered here uh so
could you please highlight on that
yeah so actually that is being something
that we discussed earlier also so this
this is not just based on the live
sessions but you will have an ac you
will have access to all the asynchronous
courses
and then right now sonalika will take
you to the asynchronous courses that is
actually built for anyone so anyone from
biologists to clinicians from experts
can learn from those asynchronous
materials so those courses are designed
in a way to make sure that you
go through uh the
content and learn about what we will be
covering sessions too so i think if you
start going through that material which
is uh available online and you can do it
from actually anywhere i i think that
would be really helpful for you to go
through the sessions and interact with
our mentors and design a project so all
of this is this is possible when you
start from if you are starting from
scratch and that is from the
asynchronous material on machine
learning on different type of omics data
on different type of application
projects everything is available on
learn or mix logic and i think snarlica
will be able to show you how you can get
started there
thank you so much sir
if there are any other questions you can
post in the chat box and we would be uh
glad to answer them
now i am going to launch the poll to
know you all better and my first
question is what is your current level
of education
and my second question is what are your
research interests
i would be keeping the poll on for 30
seconds
i request you all to please uh vote
those who have completed their vote
please make sure that you go along with
me make sure that you are on the portal
learn.almostlogic.com i'll just share
the link real quick in the chat box for
you all
now as dr mohit mentioned that we have a
various asynchronous materials which
will help you get started with the
program
so let me just guide you through
the asynchronous material first of all
and then we'll go towards the program
and registration
let's give 10 more seconds for the poll
okay thank you everyone for casting your
vote i'm just ending the poll now
so once you are here on the omixlogic
portal you would be able to find few
bars here as courses programs projects
and research go to the courses tab and
just type
introduction and you would be able to
find a lot of introductory courses so if
you are new to bioinformatics let's say
you are from a biotechnology background
or microbiology or biomedical and you
have no clue of what bioinformatics is
but you want to begin with that then
make sure that you go through and
explore this course introduction to
bioinformatics we have various
introductory courses on r and python as
well so let's just go through one of the
introductory courses
you can just begin with introductory
courses and then have the basic
knowledge and you would definitely be
able to go along with all the session
material there
so these are few of the lessons which
are there on the co in the course of
introduction to data science for python
you could also practice each and every
code block on the console itself like
elia showed you and help you practice
with few of the stuff so you need not
install any jupyter notebooks or stuff
but actually just learn the code and
practice it then and there
now coming to the program page how you
get to the program page and how you
register yourself for the program so
visit the programs on the omixlogic
learn portal and just find the program
that is machine learning for biomedical
data science
now once you are here on the program
page you would be able to find all the
details that are related to the program
and also the schedule of the program and
the session topics that are going to be
covered on various dates for the program
the title and also the topics that would
be covered
and once you uh scroll down you would be
able to find three levels that are
beginner intermediate and advanced
levels
now these levels are being divided just
based on the prerequisites or that are
being provided for these each different
levels and you can enroll yourself for
whatever level you want to based on uh
the facility that you would like to
gain from the program
you just have to click on the select
option and proceed with your payment
checkout gateway
also you would be able to find a list of
courses that are recommended to complete
for the program and also you would have
the access to each and every program
here the introduction program by info in
python by uh then the r and bio ml
course is there as well where you will
learn about statistical analysis and
machine learning and also we have
various specialized projects here in the
courses tab itself where you could learn
how different sorts of analysis could be
applied to solve a research problem and
then how you analyze or interpret the
results from the server
so now let me just take a minute to help
you navigate how you have to reach to
various projects that we have also the
courses so if you wish to
view the courses that are available
under the courses tab on the learn
portal just click on the course and you
would be able to find all the courses
that we have
so i was just talking about the bio ml
course i would really like to take you
through that as well and those who are
want to carry out a research project a
bioinformatics research project but come
from a different field they can
definitely take up this course and learn
from it
and then the projects which i was
talking about you just have to click on
the projects and you will get a list of
sample projects that we have in which we
have tried to analyze a lot of uh
different sorts of fields including the
data sets and then how you reach to the
final analysis how you run the pipeline
on the server get your results and then
you how you interpret your results to
get biological meaningful insights
and also those who feel that the program
cost for them is not
right
right now and or if they're very busy
with their
ongoing research or their ongoing
commitments to their institute they can
definitely go ahead with taking a basic
subscription for the omixlogic learn
portal where they would have the access
to all the courses and all the projects
that are present here under the courses
tab on the learn portal they can begin
with uh going ahead to have an
understanding of these various courses
and once they feel that they are now
ready to go ahead with the
specialization maybe then they can
definitely go ahead with taking the
program enrollment and advance their
knowledge of research
so we have few of the questions
uh so no no mala all these courses uh
yes they have one particular fee that is
a basic subscription dollar ten but you
need not pay the fee individually for
each and every course the dollar 10
includes the access to all the courses
and all the projects that are here on
the course under the courses tab on the
learn portal
sonam is asking i'm exposed to python
art omix pipelines machine deep learning
in an intermediate expert level how
would this program help me
so i would like dr mohit to please uh
help you sonam with this question
over to you dr mohamed
okay so let me take the question itself
so sonam you are saying that you have
already an intermediate or an expert
level for uh the various fields python r
omix and also uh omix pipelines and
machine and deep learning i would like
to ask you have you implemented these
different sorts of concepts to carry out
your own individual research project or
not you can unmute yourself maybe and
let me know that
and also when you say that you have an
intermediate or expert level for these
different fields is it specific to
bioinformatics or to carry out the
biomedical analysis or just in general
uh you know about the basics and stuff
yes ola you are perfectly right the 10
allows you to explore all the courses
without the mentor support
so i'll tell you what exactly dollar
trend does so let's say if you go to the
transcriptomics course uh like whichever
course you go to you will find some
start content on the course
i think i have a slow net yes so when
you go to the courses uh tab
uh whatever course you want to explore
you will find few of the
lessons that are unstarred and many of
them are start so the 10 basic
subscription is basically to get you the
access to all the start content that is
there uh in the courses
on the uh amazon portal
and to talk about the server
where you are going to uh carry out the
pipelines and run the analysis and then
get your results and try and learn to
interpret them
for the server for the ten dollar basic
subscription you would just get the
access to few of the demo pipelines here
so you already have the demo pipelines
where the data set has already been uh
uploaded and you just have to run the
pipeline just to learn uh how the
pipeline could be run using the
different algorithms and what these
algorithms are actually doing uh at the
back end the knowledge to that would be
given in the courses and then you will
get the result from this one pipeline
and you can then analyze the result and
interpret your results accordingly and
how to interpret your results have been
very well explained in the courses as
well so that is why taking the courses
to
run the pipeline and actually learn how
the pipeline has to be run and how you
interpret the results is important so
let's do just one pipeline real quick so
if you click on start the data has
already been uploaded you'll get to know
what these different modules are uh
trying to do at the back end so once you
click on start the next step is
trimomatic which gets highlighted right
so you have to click on chromomatic and
after that the next the next session
that gets highlighted is pcr clean now
once you click on pcr clean then the
next step would be highlighted that is
baudi 2d the next algorithm now to
understand what is dramatic why is it
required what is pcr clean again
everything is mentioned in the courses
itself so this is the way how you can
run your pipelines and get the result
and then you have to click on the rsam
expression table uh just to get your
expression table and simply end the
pipeline so you see how easy it is that
you could quickly run a pipeline and
then you would get your results and
analyze them accordingly
any further questions
okay so now i'm dropping in my mail id
in the chat box
it's marketing other fine dot bio and
you can reach our doctor mohit at
mumhoot at the reply dot bio
with any queries or issues uh you face
and you would like to proceed with and
uh also let me just quickly share with
you the link to the program page and
also the link to the basic subscription
which you can take and go ahead with
learning about the various courses that
are available on the learn portal
find the pricing module here for the
basic subscription
and sonam i'm waiting for your answer if
you are here please let me know
and here is the link to the program page
okay then thank you everyone for joining
uh so we do have great scholarships for
that ola i'll share the scholarship form
for you we don't want that the financial
burden should actually uh crush someone
from learning about anything the way you
mentioned so we do have great
scholarships that we offer to students
who are uh
in the field of this research and uh
very much motivated to learn a lot so
ola please fill out the scholarship form
we'll just review your application and
then we'll get back to you with the
possible scholarship that could be
provided to you for uh this program
thank you everyone for joining and have
a great day it was great having you all
with us today and uh don't forget the
mail ids it's marketing either at pine
dot bio and more with other pine dot bio
and okay natalia is asking
how do you decide whom to give
scholarships in italian when you will
fill the scholarship form you are
supposed to upload your cv and also you
are supposed to give us two references
right based on your cv and based on your
prior research experience or let's say
your knowledge or your background we are
going to review the applications based
on that
i hope that answers your question
natalia thank you so much everyone for
joining
great perfect
bye take care
you